c'est sur cette base de l'armée de
l'Ernée irlandaise à Eindhoven dans le
sud du pays que vous le dire Zelinski a
été accueilli dimanche par le Premier
ministre néerlandais une visite surprise
a pris un déplacement en Suède qui
intervient deux jours après un feu vert
de Washington pour la fourniture à Kiev
d'avion de combat américain F16 par les
Pays-Bas et par le Danemark le président
ukrainien a salué une décision
historique
les avions F-16 vont apporter
certainement un regain d'énergie de
confiance et de motivation au combattant
comme aux civil je suis sûr que cela
sera bénéfique à l'Ukraine et à toute
l'Europe
depuis le début de l'invasion russe qui
œuvre réclame des avions des pays
occidentaux pour faire le poids face aux
forces russes les Pays-Bas possèdent à
ce stade 42 avions F-16 le Premier
ministre néerlandais a précisé que les
détails de la livraison des appareils et
leur quantités seraient déterminés
ultérieurement après consultation de ses
partenaires
nous devons nous assurer que
l'atterrissage et le décollage des
avions pourront avoir lieu de manière
sûre en Ukraine car les F-16 sont des
avions très sensibles
il faut s'assurer que les conditions en
termes d'infrastructures soit remplie
l'officialisation de la livraison F-16
intervient au lendemain d'une frappe
meurtrière des forces russes à
tcherniggives dans le nord de l'Ukraine
reste à former les pilotes de l'armée
ukrainienne à ce type d'appareil de
combat une coalition de 11 pays sera
chargé de les préparer à compter de la
fin du mois pour que les pilotes soient
opérationnels début 2024